the road to crushing is militarily at
least has been long bloody and brutal
the battle scars are everywhere we
travel through villages under is just a
few weeks ago pushing them out has come
at a hefty price but the extremists who
once had all this area and 10,000,000
people in their Caliphate who controlled
land across two countries roughly the
size of Britain have been whittled down
to a small pocket of just a few
kilometers from their positions across a
small strip of farmland the advancing
soldiers of the us-led coalition are so
close they can actually see their prey
just across from the village the
remaining is extremists are frantically
preparing for their last stand you can
see a number of women dressed in burkas
and there are children there too
with just a few hundred is fighters left
many appear to be digging in for a
battle to the death there's evidence of
a makeshift camp with a number of tents
it's here the coalition soldiers say is
families are being held as human shields
that's halted the coalition attacks for
now although there's the odd artillery
it's just to remind them they are
surrounded but the Coalition is counting
the end in days not weeks there's a
confidence about them and the outcome at
this stage seems inevitable there is
nowhere for the remaining is fighters to
go now and the coalition is constantly
reminding them they are coming after
them and there is no escape
is retreated and retreated quickly and
many appear to have been foreign
nationals signs are if a family probably
stayed here because there are small toys
left behind just blankets and a pillow
and in this suitcase there's a Calvin
Klein watch woman's glove part of a book
with which was French a French what
appears to be part of a diary or a
letter in which the writer talks about
all the amputations all the injuries the
torture and imprisonment is worth it for
alle and a child's drawing showing the
Islamic flag and a plane dropping bombs
on houses and some sort of weaponry in
return with food supplies cut and
circled by troops some are streaming out
into the desert down and humanitarian
corridor some appear to be the war
wounded this man with burns to his face
shrapnel wounds and a badly fractured
arm had had some surprisingly
sophisticated medical treatment injured
or not he's immediately detained as an
is fighter among the group there are
Westerners like Anissa who's from
Dunkirk and still only nineteen she has
a one-year-old girl now after marrying a
Frenchman who was already inside the
Caliphate who she insists refused to
fight I was fifteen I was big in my head
are you talking Internet Anna and I
follow only one week eternity
very much the Internet and after I go I
don't think good I I do this fast and
after I came outside even I in it I
didn't know that it was her war I didn't
know when I came here I hear bombs and I
was so scared I say I say what is
because the melancholy
talk with me he did he don't say to me
that he swore here she ended up spending
four years in that war
Lydia for him is also French from Paris
she married twice in Syria and has two
children she says both husbands were
killed in the fighting but despite it
all she says she learnt a lot I regret
and I don't forget I will get because it
was not my my way to think I came here
without knowledge and knowledge very
important since club and I didn't we
good because this makes me experience to
be strong and to be mother
they both yearn to go home to France but
like the men who are immediately
segregated fingerprinted and taken off
to prisons
the women are is suspects too they're
now headed for coalition camps for an
indefinite period they're out of I asked
control but they're still under
detention
Alex Crawford Sky News in eastern Syria